gleich meine persönliche Frage erinnern
Sie sich auch wehmütig an früher als
nahostexperte noch ein richtiger Beruf
war ja heute göbeln irgendwelche
Fußballer Rapperinnen oder Philosophen
ihren Senf zum Thema ins Netz ungefragt
was ist eigentlich aus dem guten alten
wenn man keine Ahnung hat einfach mal
die Fresse halten geworden so deshalb
stehen wir zu unserer Ahnungslosigkeit
und machen auch heute wieder ein
lupenreines
eskapismusangebot lucht in deutsche
Innenpolitik unwichtig aber wenigstens
zu ertragen diese Meldung z.B bei Forsa
steht die Union jetzt bei
32% so viel wir für die komplette Ampel
zusammen es ist der Wahnsinn sag ih der
märz kann vor Kraft kaum noch laufen ja
wobei seine persönlichen Werte aber na
ja das ist ja gar nicht der Punkt denn
plötzlich weht der Duft der nächsten
groko durch Berlin sie haben sich sogar
schon getroffen selten Gäste im
Kanzleramt Olf Scholz empfängt
Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz ein
gutes Treffen in der guten Atmosphäre es
gab am Kalbschnitzel und Bratkartoffeln
Kalbschnitzel und gute Laune steckt
vielleicht mehr dahinter wieder eine
große Koalition hier im politischen
Berlin ein wirklich heißes Gerücht eine
neue groko statt der Ampel dann geh ich
raus ja musste dann auch Robert das
groco Comeback oh mein Gott es ist so
ein Hottes Gerücht was da alles rein
interpretiert wurde allein in die Bilder
von März und Scholz auf dem Balkon haben
sie das gesehen ja ja und das
war das war natürlich Absicht dass ich
die beiden da gezeigt haben Grüne und
FDP sollen zittern im Sinne von guckt
mal wen ich auch haben könnte es gab
live schalten vors Kanzleramt inklusive
überraschend unverschämte Moderatorin
unsere Korrespondentin Jeanette klagb
steht bereit sie blickt auf diesen
besonderen Abend in Berlin an Abend mit
Olaf Sch manche können sich vielleicht
auch noch andere Dinge vorstellen für
einen
Freitagabend wow ja gefällt mir der neue
freche Ton bei Phönix nicht schlecht
übrigens trifft sich genau jetzt der
Ampel Koalitionsausschuss man weiß nur
gar nicht wozu
noch Markus Söder fordert heute Olaf
Scholz auf grün und FDP zu feuern und
zurückzukommen zum exppartner Union na
klar die Krisen werden immer mehr es ist
Herbst draußen wird's kälter da sehnen
sich die Menschen natürlich nach der
warmen Decke des Vertrauten nach grok
[Musik]
halt
könn Antwort kurz machen ja tatsächlich
groko Sonntag im ZDF März Kino ernsthaft
wer guckt so
was gute Frage ich sicher nicht übrigens
übrigens ist der Herr MZ ja nur so am
Baggern weil er gar keine anderen
strategischen Optionen mehr hat W die
Grünen zum Haupt erklärt wacht
irgendwann mit der SPD auf selber Schuld
der Kanzler wiederum sollte sich mal
fragen warum dieses groko Gerücht so
ernst genommen wird weil man seiner
Partei der SPD inzwischen maximale
inhaltliche Flexibilität zutraut und
weil er zu wenig Richtung vorgibt ich
meine der Mann weiß ja nicht mal wie ein
roter Teppich
funktioniert einfach drauf bleiben mein
[Applaus]
Gott es ist doch nicht so schwer oder so
Moment jetzt frage ich mich allerdings
gerade kann der Bundeskanzler sich
überhaupt einfach so einen neuen
Koalitionspartner nehmen also ich sag
mal rein juristisch zum Glück haben wir
hier beim ZDF eine Art
Universalgelehrten und der weiß echt
alles und zwar zu jedem Thema im Prinzip
ist das so der Bundeskanzler hat ja bei
uns die sogenannte Befehls oder
Kommandogewalt das bedeutet er kann
anderen Parteien Befehlen mit ihm zu
koaliieren und was viele aber leider
nicht das gilt laut Grundgesetz nur in
Monaten ohne R das st fest alles was
Richard David Brecht gerade gesagt hat
ist komplett falsch Herr brecht hat den
Germanistik promoviert wir bitten dies
zu
entschuldigen man kann nicht alles
wissen ist egal ist egal ich habe es in
der Zeit einfach mal selber gegoogelt es
ginge sogar ohne Misstrauensvotum
Steinmeier der Bundespräsident muss nur
das ampelkabinett entlass lassen und
dann macht Scholz sich mit März ein
neues mein Tipp die SPD benutzt das
Gerücht um ihre verhaltensauffälligen
ampelpartner zu disziplinieren dabei
haben die Sozen doch weiß Gott genug
eigene Probleme was sind z.B heute ihre
Inhalte die der SPD ich weiß es
nicht ernsthaft für welche Themen steht
die SPD in der Ampel auch wenn jetzt
alle nur noch über Migration reden
überrascht uns doch mal mit weiß ich
nicht was sozialem Mieterschutz solche
Sachen
oder wie wär es mal mit besserem
Personal Stichwort Nancy fäser Freunde
ja am Dienstag hatte sie als
Innenministerin bei all dem was gerade
so abgeht auf den Straßen Stichwort
offen gelebter Judenhass ernsthaft Zeit
für Sondierungsgespräche mit der
häsischen CDU nach dem alten Motto
Hessen first kurz gesagt so wird das
nichts mit dem was ich die SPD nach der
letzten Bundestagswahl so
zusammengeträumt hat ich sag euch ein
Sieg bei einer Bundestagswahl des reicht
mir nicht ich will mehr ich bin fest
davon überzeugt wir stehen an der
Schwelle zu einem sozialdemokratischen
Jahrzehnten und schon steht er bei 14%.
na ja das ist wohl der legendäre SPD
Humor groko ist also in SE Freunde wohl
auch aus Angst um die Demokratie bzw aus
Angst vor der AFD dabei Stärken große
Koalitionen den politischen Rand ist ja
so die AFD ist quasi ein Kind der ganzen
grokos der letzten Jahre in diesem Sinne
herzlich Willkommen zu Vorsicht Falle
Nepper Schlepper groko Freunde mit
Ulrich von
hesen guten Abend guten Abend ein
rätselhafter Fall von Selbsttäuschung
erschüttert die Republik immer mehr
Deutsche reden sich die groko schön wir
älteren aber können uns noch gut
erinnern wie die letzte groco war damals
2021 nämlich Scheiße scheißechuldigung
es war ja nicht all schlecht guck guck
bei dem dummen Kind hier geht's schon
los mein Gott das waren bleierne Jahre
Stillstand keiner weiß ob sich das Land
jemals erholen wird von seinen grokos na
das ist spannende Sache sage ich doch
von wegen große Koalitionen lösen große
Probleme Madame hatte 10 Jahre
Aufschwung plus niedrige Zinsen und was
hat sie draus gemacht
nüte Bildung digit
Infrastruktur alles vergammelt und wenn
jetzt wirklich die olle groko
zurückkommt wer kriegt dann wohl das
Verkehrsministerium aber nicht die CSU
ja wer denn sonst dann bewirbt sich 3
Sekunden später ein schlecht
verkleideter Mann namens Rudi Scheurer
um den
Job die ampe so nervig sie ist startet
das größte bahnsanierungsprogramm aller
Zeiten die wiederum ist der Grund dafür
dass wir beim Thema Energiewende und
Stromleitungen brutal hinterherhängen
oder nehmen wir Digitalisierung
Deutschland ist in der EU auf Platz 18
von 27 bei der digitalen Verwaltung
Katastrophe gut andererseits der
seiberraum ist zunächst einmal keine
physische
Dimension eben der seiberraum ist immer
noch im
Altenheim auch ein gutes Stichwort 2025
ist der Kipppunkt bei der Rente weil
diese Frau in 16 Jahren keine Zeit hatte
für eine
Rentenreform Abhängigkeit von Putin
groko kaputte Bundeswehr groko soll ich
weitermachen ja gut die Leute sehen sich
scheinbar trotzdem danach zurück wegen
der schlimmen Ampel ja die Ampel schitet
den ganzen Tag das sind wir doof hey
wenn ihr weniger Streit wollt dann lasst
uns doch nicht zurückgehen ins Jahr
2021 sondern gleich ich nach
1957 absolute Mehrheit für die Union und
Konrad Adenau nur Männer im Kabinett
Null Streit wunderbar eine Union regiert
ein Opa macht die Ansagen so geht
Demokratie da hatte auch noch keine
Angst dass irgendwelche Nazis an die
Regierung kommen die saßen da eh schon
ja aber ich weiß nicht me die spießigen
50er ja ja aber es gab auch gutes z.B
durften die Ehefrauen durften nur
arbeiten wenn der Mann das genehmigt hat
damit der Haushalt nicht leidet ach so
ah der
Weinbrand danke Schätchen
danke na dann
Stößchen Vorsicht volle ne Schlepper
Freunde und nun eine weitere Folge meine
Damen und Herren unserer beliebten Serie
Probleme die man echt hätte kommen sehen
müssen es ist völlig überraschend wieder
Herbst geworden Erkältungszeit man
könnte auch sagen Alarmstufe Rotz in
deutschen Kitas ja ja und schon
wieder schon wieder droht
medikamentenmangel so jedenfalls die
Warnrufe aus den Apotheken genau wie in
der letzten Erkältungssaison wissen Sie
noch am meisten fehlen im Moment
Antibiotika Schmerzmittel
Erkältungsmittel
antiallergiker eigentlich fehlt
alles nur noch
Beruhigungsmittel und die habe ich alle
selber
genommen tatsächlich ist die Lage sogar
noch etwas schlimmer als vor einem Jahr
da waren 300 Medikamente vom
Bundesinstitut für Arzneimittel als
knapp eingestuft jetzt sind schon über
500 darunter nicht ganz unwichtige wie
Antibiotika Krebsmedikamente oder
Blutdrucksenker das heißt die lustige
apothekenrally geht wieder los yay vor
allem wenn sie auf im Land wohnen ja
klar woher soll man Medikamente kriegen
zum Glück ist bald
Halloween Fiebersaft oder
Saures coole Zombie Schminke welche
Schminke süß oder ja Til Schweiger
verfilmt das gerade unter dem Titel kein
safthasen wird bestimmt
toll immerhin jetzt mal die gute
Nachricht haben wir seit kurzem in
Deutschland einen Lieferengpass gesetzt
das verpflichtet den Großhandel
theoretisch für die wichtigsten
Medikamente einen vier Wochen Vorrat
anzulegen worauf viele fragen womit ich
habe nichts außerdem will Karl
Lauterbach die Pharmaproduktion zurück
nach Europa locken kostet allerdings
Zeit und Geld österreich hat gerade 50
Millionen Euro in das einzige und
übrigens letzte Penicillin Werk des
Kontinents investiert ja ich sag mal gut
angelegt wirklich gut angelegt wir
Deutschen subventionieren lieber
Chipfabriken und appellieren ansonsten
ans patientengewissen das schaffen wir
nur wenn Vernunft das Gebot der Stunde
ist und das Gebot der Stunde der
Vernunft ist bitte keine
Hamsterkäufe was hat er gesagt sorry
sorry ich habe nicht zugehört ich habe
nicht zugehört ich musste noch schnell
in die apothekeuld gut ja mein Gott Karl
das haben wir doch in der Pandemie
gelernt vor Hamsterkäufen warnen bewirkt
exakt das Gegenteil ja nämlich
Hamsterkäufe klar werden Eltern nach den
Erfahrungen des letzten Winters auf
sicher was bunkn von dem Zeug was sind
denn das für bananenvorschläge aus
Lauterbachs Ministerium als nächstes
schlägt er wahrscheinlich vor kranke
Kinder einfach ganz täglich bei Ikea ins
Bällebad stecken übrigens eine Ursache
des ganzen Elends
das ist schlimm ne finde ich auch
ja eine Ursache des Elends hat eindeutig
mit Geiz ist Geil zu tun bei Generika
tobt nämlich ein Preiskampf und unsere
Kassen feilschen bei den Herstellern um
rekordrabatte so Konzerne wiederum
verkaufen ihren Stoff aber lieber
Überraschung an Länder die mehr zahlen
oder sie wandern ins Ausland ab wo man
billiger produziert vor allem nach
Indien und China ich habe mal gesagt
dass die Chinesen gar keine Atombombe
brauchen sondern sie liefern uns einfach
gar keine Antibiotika mehr und dann
haben wir hier ein lebenswichtiges
Problem in
Europa jetzt bringt sie die Chinesen
noch auf
Ideen mein Gott sicher mehr Geld für
farmahersteller heißt in der Konsequenz
wohl höhere Krankenkassenbeiträge das
ist aktuell schwer zu vermitteln nur
konzentrieren sich diese Firmen dann
eben weiter auf Produkte die Geld
bringen aktuell z.B werden Sie gelesen
haben auf die die extrem gehibte
abnehmspritze osempik ja die
wunderabnehmspritze ja
osempik von der dänischen Firma Novo
Nordisk an der Börse wertvoller als BMW
Mercedes und VW zusammen kein Witz für
eine abnehmspritze ist eigentlich ein
diabetesmedikament das nebenbei den
Appetit senkt bei den ganzen
dickmacherfmen jagt jetzt wahrscheinlich
eine Krisensitzung die nächste
okay Leute wir dürfen jetzt nicht in
Panik geraten aber in dieser neuen
Studie steht mit osempik schwindet nicht
nur der Appetit generell sondern vor
allem das Verlangen nach Süßem so eine
scheiße aber auch das Verlangen nach
salzigem
Essen stattdessen vermelden Patienten
mehr Lust auf Fisch Obst und oh
Gott
Gemüse
[Applaus]
ja da sind schon Börsenkurse in den
Keller gegangen von dickmacherfmen und
der Hype um die abnehmspritze ist ein
weltweites Phänomen auch influencer
helfen selbstverständlich fleißig mit
z.B unsere netzreporterin Larissa hallo
Larissa hallo her Oliver sind diese
Spritzen jetzt sowas wie der gamechanger
für Übergewichtige Vorsicht Oliver auch
Wörter können verletzen man sagt nicht
mehr übergewichtig das heißt jetzt
bodymass Index
herausgeforderte ja aber ich glaube bei
ihnen sagt man ästhetisch
benachteiligt kann das sein ja aber das
ist ja gerade das geniale an der Spritze
hier man muss heute überhaupt nicht mehr
so aussehen wie
sie nein nein früher da dachte man einer
wie sie der wird sich läfig immer weiter
so
ausdehnen weil sie auch kein Sport
machen dies das weil sie sich ich sag
mal frei raus aufgegeben haben bis man
sie dann eines Tages mit ein Kran aus
dem Fenster
holt aber jetzt dank dieser kleinpritze
kann er auch für sie wahr werden der
Traum Hosengröße
38 ich setze ihn gleich mal oh du meine
Güte du wirst so wunderschön sein ich
schwöre nein danke ich will nicht
wunderschön sein und diese Spritze hier
ersetzt weder Sport noch gesunde
Ernährung das Entscheidende ist aber was
viele nicht wissen die natürlich jetzt
auf die Spritze spekulieren dass man sie
ein Leben lang nehmen muss das heißt es
gibt es auch in Studien untersucht
sobald man die Spritze wieder absetzt
nimmt nimmt man wieder ein Gewicht
zu ja und Heroin musst du auch immer
weiter neehmen wenn du einmal angefangen
hast ja und davon sind die Leute ja auch
begeistert
also manchmal könnte man denken sie sind
richtig dumm also wissen sie so richtig
dumm ja ja ich verstehe einfach nicht
warum Sie Werbung machen für so ein
Quatsch hallo ich mach doch keine
Werbung das weiß ich entschieden zurück
ganz ehrlich ich bin einfach nur ein
mega Fan der Qualitätsprodukte we goofi
und osempik Schank werden ohne
Anstrengung für nur 300 € im Monat das
ist ja irre das ist doch kein Werbung
wenn ich sowas sage ja das ist einfach
wirklich mein Meinung und zwar nicht er
seit die mir neulich dieses extrem nice
Fahrzeug vor die Tür gestellt haben
einfach so ich sch die sind so nett auch
vom Charakter ja Herr Oliver sehen Sie
doch bitte die Chancen weil ganz ehrlich
also so wie sie aussehen und da könnten
Sie vielleicht ich sag mal höchstens
noch als ein curvy Model
arbeiten kennen sie kurvy Model so nennt
man die Models heute die zu viel
curvywurst essen ja wollen Sie denn gar
nicht dazu gehören zu den wirklich
Reichen und schön Stars wie die
Kardashians oder Elon Musk sollen mit
ozempik abgenommen haben mittlerweile
gibt es sogar einen eigenen Tanz
[Musik]
dazu ja toll aber das Zeug wirkt ja wohl
nur bei sehr adipösen Menschen habe ich
gelesen das ist doch kein Lifestyle
Produkt für die doof Kim Kardashian oh
mein Gott der hat Kim kardeschen
beleidigt also wirklich Herr Oliver
begreifen sie denn nicht das hier das
ist die wichtigste Erfindung seit ich
habe keine Ahnung seit dem Buchdruck ach
was rede ich da viel wichtiger weil W
hat jemals von einem Buch abgenommen
keiner also pass auf ich demonstriere
das jetzt hier mal live im Fernseher
also ich esse Achtung einen ganzen
erdnutzflip nein vor allen Augen einfach
so ohne Scham wie eine hemmungslose
Fressmaschine
guck und jetzt Habu ich mir direkt die
Spritze rein
guck und bleib exakt so wie vorher ich
feier das voll so ja Oliver und jetzt
machen wir aber noch schnell zusammen
diesen spritzentanz dafür hat mir osik
nämlich extra Geld gegeben also linke
Hand 5 6 7
was machen Sie da Larissa meine Damen
Herr vielen
[Applaus]
Dank hallo Leute ich bin der heute sch
memeersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
Scheiß und
Lied memes wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den
Kanal was zur Hölle ist ein
[Musik]
memersteller